beh la categoria questa partita da parte
nostra
che cosa qua
numero è successo stasera niente è vero
non è niente in confronto a quello che
sarebbe potuto accadere
edwards ha colpe da soli o no
l'avrei dovuto prevedere come avresti
potuto prevedere e ancora il mio
compleanno
anche se ti ho detto che non voglio
regalo qualcosa c'è qualcosa
e questa è una delle tante scene di new
moon voglio dire non vi ho raccontato
niente perché l'hanno fatta vedere
ovunque qualsiasi canale della
televisione tipo mesi e mesi prima che
uscisse il film quindi l'unica cosa che
voglio chiedere che se non vi volete
rovinare la visione del film
chiudete adesso il video magari ve lo
vedete in un secondo momento perché il
video contiene degli sprechi
dopo quello che è successo oggi ho
capito che dobbiamo andarcene mia va
bene dammi qualche giorno ed a dire il
mio padre
quando dico noi
intendo quelli come me ma chi degli uomo
sessuali in appello
non ci fa qualcuno
non che non ce la posso fare addio bella
ecco
a questo tutto bella scopre che l'unico
modo per riuscire ancora a sentire la
presenza di edward che compare in
maniera molto figlia è proprio quello di
venir meno al patto che hanno fatto nel
bosco e incominciare a commettere delle
pazzie lavati i denti
no mi ha abbandonata navali ti prego
bella bene te ne pentirai
ciao ciao è un
devi scusare compito ha promesso che mai
abbandona mettono ogni bandiera nider o
no non ti lascerò online ti devo
lasciare a questo punto dal basso della
sua depressione dopo aver scoperto che
l'uomo lupo il cui compito è proprio
quello di ammazzare vampiri e che quindi
non potrà mai essere amico della persona
che lei ama di più ma che ciononostante
lì per proteggerla da una roccia sfigata
che la vuole scatenare in quanto il suo
fidanzato è stato ucciso da è porno
l'episodio precedente
lei dice di commettere l'ultima pazzia
per rivedere edward
si no
[Musica]
all
getty
sento un po
[Musica]
bellamy da scoprire da elis che edward è
andato in italia farsi ammazzare perché
perché pensa che lei sia morta e cosa
succede questo il momento più divertente
del film quando arriva lo è ci dipingono
come un popolo che guida trattori tra
loro figli l'autostrada capito usano la
macchina fino alla fine cosa succede
bella salva edward dopo
fermati bello diventerà comunque la
vampira l'ho visto io posso mai e manzo
sti reazione quel vecchio socio un
ragazzino e questo è fondamentale
e questo è il modo in cui inizia il new
moon ossia non l'ho detto niente perché
l'hanno fatto vedere nel trailer per
tipo mesi e mesi in ogni canada ecco è
questo e questo è praticamente e questo
praticamente e questa è uno dei tanti
scene di new moon non vi ho detto niente
affanculo
[Applauso]